000 net migration is six hundred and six
thousand people into
2022 lower than expected Tom yeah and
that's what we're seeing from the ons in
these figures which have just been
published so they're saying that I mean
it is a high figure it's still higher
than the 500
000 more than 500 000 we had in the
previous release uh for the six months
previous
um and where that has come from is in
work and study visas and in humanitarian
Visas so uh work obviously a lot of that
is going to Health and Social care
there's a specific Visa room for that uh
study visas we know that's become very
popular post pandemic as well but also
because of the graduate route which lets
students stay for two years afterwards
if they're working but also humanitarian
you know these are very popular with the
public that's things like Afghan
resettlement Ukrainian resettlement Hong
Kong resettlement but what the ons is
saying is that all of those seem to be
slowing in terms of their growth so this
is higher than it was before but it is a
leveling off it's not the million figure
that we saw or the figure of around
seven hundred thousand a lot of people
were expecting today
um so this is um yeah less than we were
expecting really uh still high but seems
to be taping off to that'll probably be
good news for the government it is still
a record figure there's lots to go
through here we'll be going through it
throughout the day but I think that is
the headline it's less than expected
still very high